Where do you see this going?
When you look at these kinds of emerging technologies,
not necessarily emerging anymore,
established now,
but still,
you know,
a,
a new thing in relative terms of human history.
Where do you see this going and does it get more intrusive?
Does it get deeper into our lives?
Like what,
what,
and when you look at new technologies like augmented reality and things on those
lines,
do you see new possibilities and new things that make things even more
complicated?
I mean,
yeah.
I mean we just have to assume that we,
we naturally use more and more technologies,
more and more things become open,
more and more things,
uh,
increase their velocity.
There's more communication,
not less.
Like this is not going away and it's just,
it's just a question of what we do with it.
So where,
where I want it to go as and where I want Twitter specifically to go is I,
you know,
I,
I think it's existential right now that we,
we,
we have global conversations about some things that will become crisis,
climate change being one of them.
There is no one nation state that's going to solve that problem alone.
Economic disparity being another,
the the rise of Ai and uh,
job displacement and just like us offloading decisions to these,
to these algorithms,
those are the things that,
that no one nation,
no one community is going to solve alone.
It takes the entire world to do so.
So I want to make sure that we're doing our best to get people seeing these
global conversations and ideally participating in them because it helps,
it helps us solve the problems faster.
I just believe that more open society allows us to solve problems much faster.
So you in many ways see Twitter is having some sort of a social responsibility
in this discussion.
Totally.
Yeah.
And I think a big part of his,
like right now,
like how are we,
how are we ensuring that there is more healthy contribution to that global
conversation?
And you know,
I,
I just think it's,
it's so critical that we start talking about the things that are facing all of
us,
not just one nation.
I do think you know that that's where our current model really puts the world at
a disadvantage because it incentivizes more of the echo chambers,
which lead to things like nationalism.
Instead of taking the broader picture and looking at what's happening around the
world to all people,
to all of humanity.
What do you do though to balance the conversation or what responsibility do you
think you have to balance the conversation in terms of the way conservatives
view at versus the way liberals and progressives view it?
Balance it shows there,
is there a responsibility,
do you have responsibility or is it just leave it up to the people and let them
figure it out the same way they figured out hashtags and,
and everything else.
I,
I think we have a responsibility to make it easier to do that easier.
How so?
Right now it's just,
it's just too hard.
Most most people will not venture off this other similar mindset.
They will,
they will not venture out.
They will not break their bubble.
Um,
but if you,
because it's right now on the surface,
it's just so hard to do that.
I,
I can only follow accounts and I have to,
I have to look into and just imagine like,
you know,
trying to get an understanding of your own politics.
People can't just look at your bio,
they have to look through all your tweets,
they have to listen to a bunch of your podcasts and whatnot.
And that's a bunch of work.
If we shift it more towards topics and interest,
at least we have the potential to see a bunch more perspectives.
We see that though is the simplest thing as I follow hashtag follow a topic.
Like why can't you just follow warrior's Twitter or uh,
um,
you know,
NBA,
Twitter,
why do you have to go and find all the coaches and the players and,
and the team.
So we can do that.
We can help make that a whole lot easier for folks.
So there's something like Brexit or something like that.
So if you go to Hashtag Brexit,
you're going to get the whole conversation,
you're going to get the pros,
the cons,
the left,
the right,
the whole deal,
the centrists you're going to get everybody versus following the people that you
already follow that agree with what you think the probability is higher,
that you'll get more,
you'll get more variety perspective and not even doesn't even follow Brexit,
follow vote leave if you want to leave.
But within that topic there might be some dissenting opinions and you get to
choose whether you,
those inform you,
whether that emboldens your position or not.
But,
and,
and again,
I'm not saying that we should force that upon it,
but it's not easy to even do that today.
Right?
The only tool we give you is finding and following the accounts and that.
But people search hashtags,
they do start trash.
They don't,
they send their timeline.
I mean it is small percentage of people that,
people that really know Twitter know how to do that.
But most people,
they fall into account and they stand the timeline and what their world is,
their timeline.
Hashtags can be corrupted to totally.
They can be gamed.
It can be gamed and taken over.
I took over Hashtag Vegan cat go to Hashtag [inaudible] in.
What is,
what is that?
It's a wrap.
That's mine now.